so there's a new story out there that
solves a little bit of a mystery in that
ever since the 1960s where people first
flew space probes around the far side of
the Moon so the side of the Moon that we
don't actually get to see from the earth
and started taking pictures they found
that actually rather bizarrely the far
side of the Moon looks very different
from the near side of the Moon in that
there are many more mountain ranges on
the far side of them that the near side
of the moon has some craters but mostly
it's these sort of big flat planes these
things called seas or Marez so it's
always been a bit of a mystery as how
you can form an astronomical body like
the moon with one side of it so
different from the other side of it
so there's now an explanation as to
probably how this came about which is it
there's a reasonably well accepted
theories to how the moon formed which is
sometime early in the formation of the
solar system there was no moon but some
other body in the early solar system
came along and smacked into the earth
sort of threw a whole load of material
up into space and that material
coalesced to form the moon and so this
new idea is that maybe it didn't
originally coalesce to form one body
maybe it initially coalesced to form two
bodies one rather larger than the other
and in fact you can do that and the two
objects will happily share the same
orbit for some considerable time but
eventually they'll probably bump into
each other and this is what and bumping
into it each other is probably the right
way of thinking about it in the sense
that they did merge with one another but
it wasn't a huge massive collision
because if you have a huge massive
collision either you'll smash them to
pieces or your very least you will end
up forming a huge impact crater or
something like that so probably the two
sort of merged together relatively
gently and when they merged together the
place the side of the Moon where all
these extra material got added would
form a whole load of mountains it's
basically mostly the material you've
added on but also that's kind of the
impact on the on the surface will kind
of create folds and new new mountains
and so on there will be some molten rock
form because it's still reasonably hot
and all this happens there's a
reasonably energetic collision that
Mortain rock will then flow around to
the other side of the moon and produce
the very smooth kind of lava flows that
we see on the other side of the moon so
this is rather neat model for actually
explaining how you can end up with a
moon that looks so different on the two
sides is this based on any evidence or
is this just a hypothesis that makes a
lot of sense it's so the the guys who've
done this have done a series of
calculations to figure out that you can
actually have these kind of three body
systems that they will coexist happily
so the earth and these two moons will
coexist happily for a long time and
actually when they do merge together you
can arrange things without being too
kind of contrived about the huckle whole
thing they will actually tend to merge
in this fairly gentle fashion they won't
smack into each other at a high speed
I suspect it will probably be kind of a
plausible theory for the foreseeable
future and that you might for example
one way of trying to figure out whether
two things whether a particular objects
is formed from two separate things is to
look at the chemical composition and see
if it varies from place to place but
here of course both the moon's formed in
the same original impact and so actually
they were probably made up a more or
less the same material and so you're
probably not really going to be able to
tell which is one moon and which is the
other when you even if you could collect
large samples from the moon I think yeah
plausible probable yeah I'll be happy
with probable it's you know if so the
essence of science is to try and come up
with the simplest explanation that
explains as many things as possible eyes
this thing called Occam's razor that
says you the simplest explanation is the
best and the nice thing is that this
single idea actually explains quite a
lot of the properties of the moon so as
such it's kind of a good theory but it
is still a theory when astronomers were
trying to figure out where the moon came
from they eventually came up with this
collision theory now they're trying to
figure out why the moon has these two
different aspects to it and again
they've come up with a collision theory
it just seems like every time there's
something they can't figure out they say
oh it must have been a bit it's always
fine smashing things into each other so
say we galaxies right the way we like to
make bigger galaxies is by smashing
smaller galaxies together it's always
fun to crash things into each other